and we begin this Sunday morning with
Republican leadership coming up empty
once again on securing the southern
border as they agree to a third
continuing resolution once again
extending the Democrat agenda set by
then house Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
back in December of 22 Republicans
initially appeared to hold tough pushing
the threat of a government shutdown in
their bid to stem the tide of over 10
million illegal migrants Crossing into
America under the Biden Administration
but in the end they caved with 107
Republicans in the house and 26 in the
Senate joining Democrats to continue
funding the government with no money and
no new security at the wideopen Texas
border now Congress has until March 1st
and March 8th to pass a federal budget
for this fiscal year which began in
October join me right now in this Sunday
morning Futures exclusive live from the
southern Border in Texas where he is up
close and personal with the issues the
chairman of the house Foreign Affairs
committee Congressman Michael McCall
chairman Nicole was one of the 107 House
Republicans to join 207 Democrats in
voting to keep funding the federal
government through early March without
new border funding Mr chairman always a
pleasure thank you for joining
us oh thanks for having me Maria so why
did you do it why did you kick the can
down the road and continue funding this
government when you are up close and
personal at the border and you see the
devastating
impact well I didn't kick any can down
the road I didn't want take my football
and go home and not play on the football
field you can't win the game if you
you're not on the field and the fact is
it would jeopardize our military
Readiness at a very dangerous time uh
our veterans and you know what to I was
with our board patrol all day yesterday
for me to come home and tell them we're
not going to give you your paychecks to
do your job that that's just insulting
what we need Maria is about a month to
get this right uh we want to get a
border security package we didn't have
it in agreement and that's too that's
unfortunate uh the whole process should
have been done a year ago but we had to
make a decision where we were I think we
made the responsible decision um going
home with their football and not being
on the field doesn't solve anything all
right Fair Point Mr chairman let's talk
about what you're seeing up close in
personal there at the border because
we're talking about murder we're talking
about fentanyl poisoning we're talking
had 10 million illegals coming into
America on President Biden's watch what
can you tell us what have you
learned uh it's gotten worse um you know
first day in office he resends the very
policies that were working that I worked
with on the Trump Administration that
being remain in Mexico migrant
protection protocols uh that was a
direct cause and effect as Bard Patrol
Chief Ortiz told us once that policy was
ascended then the magnet at pull factor
came in bringing you know 8 million
encounters at the border 300 on the
terror watch list for God's sakes when I
chaired Homeland that that would be a
big red flag the FBI director said as
much and then sadly we had two mothers
testify for our committee who lost their
loved ones one def fentel uh another
daughter got raped by MS13 gang banger
from Honduras uh this is the real life
tragedy that you're seeing you know on
the ground it's tearing apart the fabric
of this nation and it's a human tragedy
and it needs to stop uh and I'm going
down to Mexico City to talk to the
president of Mexico and all the elected
officials and government officials stop
sending fentel into the United States
stop the flow of migrants into the
United States but we can't effectuate
the Trump policies that had worked so
well without Mexico's cooperation and
that's why I'm going down there you know
uh Congressman a couple of weeks ago we
had all these demands coming from the
president of Mexico right we're not
going to help you unless you do one two
three I'm wondering who's really running
Mexico do you get a sense that the
president of Mexico is in charge or are
these dangerous drug cartels running
Mexico I you know I think the latter I
think you have a president who's playing
La Fair with him you like play nice in
your sandbox don't kill each other and
by the way bring bring home the bacon
and and that's a model that has to stop
you know under President Trump he
threatened them with tariffs and said
look if you don't agree to remain in
Mexico and it simply what that means
Maria is there political Asylum claims
are adjudicated outside the United
States what we saw yesterday is we don't
have enough detention space so they
release them Catch and Release into
society that is the key here that has to
stop and it's a it's not throwing a
bunch of money down here it's policy
changes yeah you know I thought it was
really interesting that suddenly
President Biden claims that the border
is not secure he claims he's been saying
this for 10 years Congressman now he's
admitting it with two days before New
Hampshire and 289 days uh before the
election do you believe that Republicans
can actually unite at this moment in
time against the Biden policies and
actually make a at the
border we have to and this Epiphany is
very interesting I was in the white
house with the National Security
chairman he told me I know the board is
broken I know it needs to be fixed I
know we need s significant change down
there in his words but what does that
mean I told him what it means and that
is change the policies go back to the
policies that were working under the
prior Administration we're actually
securing this border uh it's not rocket
science we can get this done and
Republicans will stand together but you
know what a lot of Democrats agree with
us and they know the maps they know this
is a 8020 issue and they know that if
they can go back home and say they did
something because it's not just here
Maria it's in New York it's in Ohio it's
everywhere Across the Nation that's
impacted and thank God my Governor has
sent the migrants to New York so they
can get a little bit of taste about what
we experience here in Texas yeah we're
going to talk with Governor Greg Abbot
tomorrow morning on mornings with Maria
over on Fox Business that'll be
important to talk about what he's been
doing there but let me get your take Mr
chairman on what's going to happened
with Alejandra mayorcas this week um
you've got another hearing uh in terms
of this impeachment hearing are you
going to be able to take this across the
finish line and impeach my
orcus we have to you know I'm one voice
but I represent 800,000 people when I go
home number one issue border and this
one man is the architect of Destruction
down here one man has caused all this
chaos uh deaths of fentel poisoning you
know danger to the country with
terrorists coming in 8 million
encounters with no legal status he is
the architect he has destroyed the
fabric of this nation he is the one who
has injured societies the founding
fathers talked about breach of public
trust was sufficient for impeachment by
the founding fathers and we intend to go
forward chairman Mark Green's doing a
great job we're working together
articles of impeachment January
31st and we will impeach them after that
all right we will be watching that Mr
chairman I know that you're going to
Mexico City and you've also been to that
uh lab where they're collecting uh fent
andol uh and you're doing Lots work
there thanks for going to the Border sir
and thank you for joining me this
morning well thanks for having me Maria
always all right Congressman Michael
Mall this morning in Texas at the
southern
border hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now